welcome to the bonus show up three very
interesting stories for you today I want
to start with a story from fortune uh I
guess it's not really Fortune magazine
anymore it's the website do they even
have a magazine at this point I really
don't know I certainly haven't read the
paper version for a very very long time
a Goldman Sachs has enacted a set of
rules that ban the firm's top employees
from contributing to certain campaigns
and as it happens one of those campaigns
is Donald Trump's campaign the rules
kicked in on the first day of September
they will apply only to partners of the
firm and they wrote a memo which
explains this rule change it was first
reported on by Politico and they say the
rules were meant to remove any
implication of pay to play four years
ago you might remember that Goldman
Sachs paid 12 million dollars to settle
charges that a former boston-based
banker had picked up some bond
underwriting business in Massachusetts
while working for and contributing funds
to the campaign's to the campaign of
then Massachusetts state treasurer and
governor hopeful Tim Cahill of course
the people on the Trump campaign are
saying wait wait wait a second we're two
months from the election and now all of
a sudden you're cutting off these
donations and this is something that
many people are saying this is actually
a violation of free speech because as we
know money is speech and blah blah blah
blah blah uh and there are a lot of real
sort of questions around this and
there's a memo that has been going
around which was obtained by fortune and
Goldman Sachs specifically says the
Trump pence campaign is an example of a
Goldman partner that they can no longer
support I don't believe that this is
really an issue of free speech I believe
that is a private company is a company
that is is not a well you know to say
it's not government funded a lot of
these companies get bailed out by the
government but let's put that aside for
now they can say you can make political
donations here but if you are in certain
positions if we have a relationship with
a candidate or the
businesses of a certain candidate we
need to avoid the appearance of
impropriety in any possibility of at
some point being accused of this
pay-to-play stuff so you're just not
allowed to donate their I have to say
Rachel I I'm not that concerned from a
free speech point of view it's more just
do you agree with this policy and if you
don't if it's so important to you to be
able to donate to whoever you want then
maybe you shouldn't be working at
Goldman Sachs and that's a choice the
employees would be free to make wouldn't
they I think so I mean I definitely
think that even if they're trying to
make a statement that this isn't a
statement it's going to come across as
kind of a bold move so to speak and I
think it's interesting and I definitely
appreciate when certain companies like
PayPal or Apple has taken dat certain
stances on issues that they that's in
accordance with their values so while I
appreciate it i don't i think it
definitely could get a little bit messy
i think one of the things that fortune
reported on because you might say okay
well goldman sachs is doing this but
wouldn't this be a problem for a lot of
companies back in july fortune reported
that SEC rules could make it nearly
impossible for the Trump pence campaign
to raise money from any private equity
managers period because between the two
of them they have so many pre existing
business relationships that would
actually violate sec rules so this is uh
on the one hand some people are slamming
Goldman Sachs on the other hand Goldman
Sachs is almost getting out ahead of
this because there are many companies
that are not changing the policy that
have the exact same issue with where
they have dealings with either the state
of Indiana visa V the the Mike Pence
administration any of diff of Donald
Trump's different real estate or or
other development businesses etc etc so
I actually believe that this is Goldman
Sachs getting ahead of a potential
problem uh rather than them being the
outlier who is just trying to hurt
Donald Trump